(audience cheering)
(upbeat guitar music)
♪ Your arms are warm,
but they make me feel ♪
♪ As if they're made of cold, cold steel ♪
♪ A simple kiss like a turnin' key ♪
♪ A little click and the lock's on me ♪
♪ Can't move my arms ♪
♪ Can't lift my hands ♪
♪ I won't admit to where I am ♪
♪ But I know, baby ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm in chains ♪
♪ I'm in chains, yeah ♪
♪ Should have known
passin' through the gate ♪
♪ That once inside, I could not escape ♪
♪ I never thought this
could happen to me ♪
♪ I never thought this is where I'd be ♪
♪ But, baby ♪
♪ Baby, look at me, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I said baby, baby, look at me, yeah ♪
♪ I'm in chains ♪
♪ Baby, baby, I'm in chains ♪
♪ I never thought this is where I'd be ♪
♪ I never thought that
this could happen to me ♪
♪ In chains ♪
♪ I'm in chains ♪
(audience cheering)